I I
I'm curious I'm curious to know as like
do you have one piece of content that
you've posted on the internet that has
wildly outperformed everything else
uh it is not no not butthole related
it's right I already covered all
butthole related topics
um I think uh yeah I guess the the thing
that I posted that I was like I posted
it from the set of righteous gemstones
and and like the 22 year old like little
pa kids that work on the show were like
popping in being like Oh my god dude
perfect was Adam Levine who I have a
name very similar to that guy my name is
divine this is Levine is you've switched
the D with the L and our names are
switched uh he had like a thing with he
was like texting some girl named Sumner
and um said like I'm gonna name my baby
Sumner after you and uh and it was like
he was having some kind of repair
allegedly allegedly uh and I was getting
this is how [__] up news is is people
are such fools that they just read his
name locked it as my name in their heads
and were coming after me being like [__]
you Adam like you cheating on your wife
and like girls being like I I used to
like you what the hell from Pitch
Perfect I thought you're a nice guy and
like hundreds
and I was getting like nudes like from
like like literal news organizations
from lives like local like Pittsburgh
News or whatever and being like Adam
DeVine cheats on pregnant wife and they
just like [__] it up they just like
misspelled the name and so I'm just
getting like all this [__] and so
finally I was like I'm not going to
stand for this and so I get online and
I'm on Instagram and I post a photo with
me and my wife
and uh and and I was just like I don't I
don't even know what I said like that's
not me
um I'm uh I'm a totally different guy
and a better singer ha you know but I
but my wife and I are gonna name our
future baby Sumner
and
the internet just went it was just like
I like sent it and then went and did a
scene and when I came back it had like a
hundred thousand plus likes like within
like an hour or less and then all the
little 20 year old uh pas were like what
what crazy yeah and I was like this it
was so a nothing thing for me to do but
like it just tapped into that that pop
culture moment yeah it just just broke
right into the news cycle viral Banger
yeah it's weird when [__] like like the
the murder thing it was like that it was
just like
just takes off and you have no you don't
think it's gonna take off or you have no
idea and then all of a sudden it's like
that's that's what people are talking
about yeah I I was aware that the news
hadn't gotten it all wrong that you were
upset about that and that's why I opted
to say I heard you murdered your name
do you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude